[Applause]
together we are in Vegas we are talking
to you from our hotel room kidding I
don't know why I'm so awkward I think
it's because Vegas right now has that
little like gloom over it based off and
like you know because of what happened
I just feel awkward talking about it
honestly but really be happy we're here
to have fun yeah and we plan this trip
you know a couple of weeks ago yeah
before everything happened we did what
we should try to have fun yes so that's
what I keep trying to tell myself and
then I was talking to geo before coming
and I told her like oh man like you know
as much as you want to move on like you
just you can't help but cuz this is just
recent this happened just last weekend
and so she was like well you know what
just try your best to have fun life
moves on you just can't let them win so
that's the goal for this alive
downstairs having fun so yeah we flew in
with Steven Nikki we're gonna meet them
downstairs in a bit and we're here to go
to this festival is called the Wrights
festival and it's a lantern releasing
kind of festival Nikki had invited us a
couple weeks back and so we're here now
and we're excited to see some lanterns
lift up lift off and ride and be part of
the atmosphere I really don't know what
the point of this festival dance but we
didn't do enough research but I'm gonna
ask Nikki and then maybe she'll tell us
Hey so we just got to the festival funny
cuz we actually missed the 30 mine it
was hilarious very funny people
you guys got to follow them they're
comedian Jon memmer yeah guess so
they're hilarious make sure I'm tripping
over all these right look make these
Robb Stark
yeah but we'll put their links up to
their YouTube channel and then you guys
can check them out if you haven't
already seen them on JK news because
they are our favorite guess like it is
Lucy you guys are our most requests get
everyone together your personal favorite
yeah you are okay okay so before I used
to watch YouTube back in the day like in
2010 and I used to watch both of them on
his YouTube channel where they would act
and nici ass and watch her channel if I
was a fan of Nikki Lurie letters but I
finally met her when we brought her on
for taking you though
totally fangirling she was like oh this
is disappointing it's like even more
disappointed yeah um my inner fangirl is
like super happy that we're on vacation
now so sorry keep walking nice try keep
losing my idea it's a great time guys
talking about yes okay classes I'd be
somewhere in the airplane I don't know
we don't know exactly where it looks
like fifteen years old so I could lose
my ID and nobody will even care do you
look weird enough yeah but luckily we
brought like in secondary ad so
hopefully we haven't tested it but
hopefully that passes or else we're
gonna have to be strong regardless
really prom night it will be sneaking
it's a sea
yes exactly the lantern takeoff things
should happen in about an hour oh yeah
Nicky's Oh best sell forever the lantern
takeoff detentions down for the world
and then you send them into the
atmosphere oh so that's what it is
yeah yeah cuz I was explaining earlier
I'm like so it's this thing where like
energy Oh
besides all I know is they're serving
alcohol what's that wow that's right it
looks like a street light
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
I'm looking to see if there might enjoy
with your eyeball this is so beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
he's getting food so he missed his first
for these kids in the port-a-potty dude
getting food poor dude Oh daddy you look
so cute
it's [ __ ] like a nice hater so there
is another one right we didn't miss out
together is another one butts in like 30
minutes so we gotta we gotta hurry gotta
read our intentions now we got to eat
quick and write them down does it really
matter if we write anything I think it's
you can't see anything once it's up
there take more than a wish I
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah three so party
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay there is a huge fire hazard
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys so today's the second day in
Vegas we stopped blogging thank you
he stopped blogging last night but what
we ended up doing was we went to Aria
was David Nicki we were gambling Nicki
was teaching me how to play craps was
pretty fun Oh
up with Jason Horton his wife Jason is a
guy and played the liquor store owner
and one of shaky skids
that's Isaac's first get you the red
where heaven breakfast I got to like
[ __ ] how fitting you got cook yeah it's
not really breakfast time because I know
what it sounds like
not what we're used to
[Music]
[Music]
all right if I didn't know any better by
looking at the menu I would have never
at the airport because this [ __ ] you
would not believe how much it costs the
[ __ ] here is 18 bucks how much was your
key that's dope tried the frost okay
it's still not worth 18 bucks no fell
should be worth $18 but pretty good
[Music]
[Applause]
like bad juju something he went away
from the table and then Nicky and I
started running like crazy so that was
awesome
but here we have I mean supreme storying
this yeah
we're about to eat bay-buh first okay
[Music]
[Applause]
blank
[Laughter]
I love I love lager I love travelling in
a group of other vloggers you gonna feel
bad vlogger problems
she's the one taking us to the
[Applause]
thank you for watching
[Applause]
we just sit across that matter okay
we're just breathing mix and match last
day in Vegas would be about to do
[Applause]
these tacos are from today but they have
locations here in Vegas which these open
one in LA because it's the best office
I've ever
had top of mt do these are better than
the
I agree I like mixing food before but
this one really sealed the deal for me
I'm like dude I think my snoopeh seems
like Chinese food
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so what are we doing now
[Applause]
the site of route 91 harvest
our respects through here wanted a
common their respect right before we
leave
so are they have actual memorial site
[Music]
[Applause]
throughout this whole trip there was
this eerie vibe about the city is one of
those feelings that you knew that you
couldn't be 100% happy on this trip but
by visiting the site where it all
happened I can't explain it but it gives
you some sort of peace and an emotional
peace from within I think that the fact
that people have come together to mourn
together to heal together to share their
hope together
it's the togetherness that makes it feel
not so sad and honestly I didn't think I
would get emotional but I ended up
tearing up a bit and I think I worked
out really well for this trip was the
fact that we came out for the Ryze
festival to have some fun and do the
whole Lantern thing but ended up being a
lot more spiritual and a lot more
reflective just overall meaningful our
hearts go out to the victims and
families and friends that have been
affected by Vegas
[Music]
[Music]